[Music]
hello everyone hope you're doing well
and enjoying next just making sure
you're all in the right room
this is CST 300 we're gonna talk about
project creation using terraform and
cost controls cool little introduction
my name is Ramsey Haddad I'm an
infrastructure cloud consultant with our
Google cloud professional services
practice I'm based right here at a San
Francisco our professional services team
works with some of our largest customers
to help them migrate their workloads and
applications to GCP I've had the
privilege of working with CoreLogic for
the past eight to nine months and
helping them move their services and
applications over to GCP I'm actually
joined here with Jim wilcott from
CoreLogic Thank You Ramsey thank you
everyone for coming and attending our
session my name is Jim Wolcott I'm a
principal of cloud solutions at
CoreLogic
and my job is to define how we operate
in the cloud we're going to have a
chance to touch on automation and labels
as part of that today cool just a an
overview of how we'll spend the next 40
minutes or so together I'll set the
context of the typical enterprise use
case I'll give you some background as
far as what terraform is and then I'll
hand it over to Jim to talk about the
core logic cloud operating model and
then we'll actually flip over to a demo
of the no label module in terraform
we'll wrap up and then leave some time
at the end for Q&A for you folks to ask
questions I'm sure you must be familiar
with the Google cloud next app but you
can actually head on over there tap this
session and as you have questions during
our presentation you can feel free to
hit the dory with any of those and we'll
make sure to get to those as well as
live questions from the audience towards
end so how many folks do we have in the
room that currently are in the
enterprise space all right cool how many
a solo developer startup folks we have
in the room
okay can't really add those up but
there's more enterprise folks here which
is there's a lot of takeaways here that
we'll talk about that really touched the
core the cornerstone of enterprise use
cases but also can be applied across
different segments of cloud consumption
so what are most of our enterprise
customers want as they move to the cloud
traditionally a lot of the conversations
that we were having with customers a few
years ago were around data center
consolidation and cost savings that
conversation has shifted somewhat from
why should I move to the cloud there's a
safe to move the cloud to how can I move
to the cloud as fast as possible and how
can you help me the idea here is we want
to introduce quick wins so that we can
actually pull away lessons and start to
actually change our behavior earlier on
in the process this allows us to
actually drive digital innovation and we
can actually maximize our velocity to
move to the cloud so we want to move
really quick we want to be able to not
repeat kind of bad behaviors in the
cloud but by doing that we need to do
that in a very secure compliant way so
repeatability and control is something
we definitely see from our customers all
of our customers want to be able to move
in a secure and compliant way and build
somewhat of an abstract approach to how
they work across multiple environments
in the cloud by abstract we mean
deploying services across multiple cloud
platforms in a very predictable way this
lends developers to focus on higher
level higher level types of work and
then we can actually reduce the blast
radius from when things go wrong so
sometimes things happen to go wrong and
we want to be able to minimize that as
much as possible with having the right
guardrails and controls in place on your
foundations and infrastructure so I
touched off on this in the beginning so
cost savings is very much a key driver
to move to the cloud but it's somewhat
become part of your point of entry to
move to the public cloud so at this
point we're seeing our customers really
wanting to get deeper understanding of
their operations to understand what
their behaviors and functions are in the
cloud so they can build high fidelity
data models to track that and change
those behaviors so the idea is that we
can actually start to get realized
deeper cost savings and then start to
improve and mature our infrastructure so
that we can save more money
so how do we get there what are the
typical things that we see are in the in
in the enterprise space where we can get
to a place where we are fully automated
we have infrastructure as code pipeline
and we're starting to actually take
those key aspects of our usage of the
cloud and then change our behavior to
get more cost savings as simple as this
sound it starts with actually defining a
set of best practices that your
organization sees the best fit for you
the idea here is to actually take key
aspects such as how you authenticate to
the cloud your identity access
management your security posture your
networking your logging and monitoring
as well as your billing foundations our
professional services team works really
closely with customers in the enterprise
space to help them step through getting
these getting started with their with
their best practices the idea here is to
actually include billing as part of your
foundation scope so that you have the
folks in the room early on that are
making key decisions that are also
responsible for your spend in the cloud
the idea here is to actually go through
a workshop to understand what you're
labeling schema should look like
make sure the procurement folks that are
building the chargeback for the public
cloud have a say as far as what the key
and value pairs are that you're actually
putting on top of your cloud
infrastructure then we move into
actually defining your GCP resource
hierarchy this is another aspect of
getting to a place where you can start
understanding your consumption in the
cloud your GCB resource hierarchy is
essentially your organization on to GCP
and there's three week three key
components there organisations folders
and projects and what this allows you to
do is group all of your DCP resources in
a way that you can query filter and then
change your behavior against that the
idea here is that when we work with a
lot of customers we'd go through an
exercise to understand how we actually
break that folder structure out a lot of
our customers will break out their
folder structure based on some
development cycle whether that be a QA
dev production a common shared folders
project and the idea is that we can then
take this folder structure and then
build a common project deployment
framework against that folder there's
actually a session later today at 2:10
p.m. called cs2 200
that'll actually step you through some
of the best practices and how you
actually get started with getting set up
with your DCP resource hierarchy we want
to be able to focus on repeatable
patterns so we want to understand what
users and operators are going to do most
in the cloud I'll talk about this in a
bit here but project creation is an
excellent example of how you can
actually start to introduce a repeatable
pattern and then build a lot of the best
practices into that so we can start
building reusable declarative templates
that allow us to scale that foundation
deployment selecting a tool so Google
wants you as a customer to select the
right tool that works for your
organization there's a few key
considerations there one is around you
know the training and skill sets
available within your org so we
encourage you to really align the vision
and direction you want to take your
developer skills there's a few options
there one is a native Google solution
called deployment manager that's fully
api supportable with Google's commitment
to open source there's also another tool
called terraform which I'll talk about
here shortly that also allows you to
build your infrastructure as code
pipeline and take some of these code of
common patterns and deploy them widely
now we have our best practices we know
our DCP resource hierarchy we have an
understanding of the foundations and
common patterns we've selected a tool
now we want to get into a place we have
extreme automation so the idea of this
is to basically codify all of our best
practices in a way that allows it to
scale them and remove any single person
that's doing manual deployments across
the environment we want to be able to
take elements of projects networks
identity access management insecurities
codify them and then also treat them
just as dynamic as our application code
terraform so just gonna give a quick
background as far as what terraform is
in this context so terraform is an open
source infrastructure as code tool by
hashey Corp terraform has this concept
of providers so it allows you to
interact with various public cloud
sources such as GCP database and Azure
as well as higher-level infrastructure
services like kubernetes terraform
declaratively defines in a set of
configuration files what you want your
to look like it'll give you a topology
that you can evolve over time and build
a work flow around Manning that
infrastructure terraform works in kind
of three key ways there's a refresh a
plan and an apply and essentially that
refresh is your infrastructure described
the plan is that real world described in
the infrastructure in a configuration
file and apply which actually builds
that infrastructure for you so we take
those three elements then we build a
module in terraform and a module is
somewhat of a black box of
infrastructure where you can
declaratively define variables and
inputs and control the behavior of that
module this allows us to kind of
encapsulate a lot of complexity around
managing traditional infrastructure we
can take those modules and then publish
them to a centralized repository so
we'll talk about kind of how we've
structured that at core logic but
ultimately terraform is an excellent
open source tool I mentioned there's a
provider for GCP so there's thousands of
contributors publishing best practices
for terraformed on GCP now coming to the
project Factory I'm sure many of you are
aware of the concept of what a project
is but a GCP project provides a trust
boundary and resource isolation for all
of your GCP resources it's a basic
resource container for policies and
infrastructure and GCP so we want to be
able to take a lot of our best practices
and because the project creation is such
an important part of how you control
your environment in GCP we want to be
able to take all those best drives and
harden them into the creation process
this allows us to stamp out projects in
a very consistent compliant way as you
see here there's a number of things that
happen in this project Factory
everything from defining a project and a
standard naming convention to attaching
it to a shared network deleting all the
default configurations it allows us to
actually go through an Associated G
suite accounts to that project but
coming down a bit it allows us to
actually can maintain a consistent
framework for how we associate projects
to billing functions associating
projects to billing accounts something
we definitely see in a field is that an
inconsistent project build process
really prevents us from making sure that
we associate projects to billion counts
in an accurate way so we can accurately
describe what labels and what billing
accounts we want to have associated when
the project gets created setting up
usage exports this is just kind of
another function here we want to be able
to enable as much metadata about our
usage in GCP so we suggest enabling the
GCE usage report and dumping that into a
central GCS bucket coming into applying
billing labels so one of the one of the
you know workshop items I mentioned
earlier around defining your best
practices is really around kind of
building that label schema and what we
want to do is actually take the set of
labels and figure out which ones are
mandatory and which ones are optional
optional and make sure that we
incorporate that as part of the
foundation build process for projects
with that I'm actually gonna hand it
over to Jim to talk about core logic and
then go from there
Thank You Ramsey okay so a little bit
about core logic core logic helps you to
find acquire and protect your home some
of the services that we have in core
logic are like we provide listing
services to real estate agents and
brokers we provide valuation information
to lenders and we provide risk
information to insurance companies we're
a global company and we're on a
three-year mission to migrate all of our
applications and products to the Google
cloud platform
so we've been working with the
professional services organization in
that endeavor and they've been fantastic
especially as we've been pushing the
envelope on some areas and engage with
their engineering teams and product
managers Ramsey asked me to post a
couple bullets about why we chose the
Google cloud platform and CoreLogic
at its heart is a data company we have
an enormous amount of property data
detail which we leverage in all of our
products and services the Google
technologies have
very synergistic with with this and so
it's a perfect match for core logic from
that standpoint and the other thing is
the Google cloud platform is really easy
to automate and I know there's a number
of csps out there that you can apply
automation to but in this case we're
gonna talk about the entire environment
from the organization down and how easy
it is to automate the entire thing so
what problem are we trying to solve how
many people here are motivated to go to
the cloud for the sake of the agility
that the cloud offers I assume most
everyone right and how many want to
achieve cost savings well we want them
both don't we right that's the problem
we're trying to solve is to derive the
highest value out of cloud computing but
it's challenging in that most of us are
coming from a static environment and
going to a dynamic one and while that
dynamic environment gives us the agility
we're seeking it also raises new
concerns things like security how do you
support fast pace environment like that
and also how do you apply cost controls
into that environment so what is the
solution to that we have to balance all
those things the need for the controls
but also to enable our cloud development
teams to do what they are there to do
which is create products and innovate
and be agile so what we did is we
gathered around and came up with some
best practices or principles right
around which we apply to everything that
we're doing first of which is automate
everything everything that we possibly
can but in that automation we also build
in security both end the foundation on
the is side also in our pipelines so we
you know pursue the goal of shifting
left in our pipe
line management to try and test
everything up in the build area
including vulnerability testing we also
embrace agility and change moving from
an environment where we have a manual
cab approval mechanism to one where we
want to have much more change smaller
changes right but many more changes so
we need to have the automation in there
as well and the way to track the
evidence of those changes we also have a
philosophy or you know in this best
practice around you build it you own it
and what's great about that is as we
transform and our application teams
gather around that goal and that best
practice is it gives us the ability to
be able to fetter eight out the support
so we birthright monitoring and logging
and we're able to actually send the
alert straight back to the application
development team they're able to resolve
incidents more quickly increasing the
availability of the products and
services that we have so how do these
best practices manifest themselves in
our core logic GCP environment we
started in July last year and we set out
with the first goal to automate the
environment from the organization down
we produced a factory for the network
which is a global network produced a
factory for our identity and access
management permissions and privileges we
produce a factory for managing firewall
rules and then we produce the
cornerstone of the entire environment
use the project factory now the project
Factory which we're going to we're going
to show some code around that have some
input points right that we have to
deliver in to create but the project
Factory is the cornerstone it provides a
landing zone that's hardened it has a
number of features that we want to layer
in for every application team that's
migrating up to GCP so if you think
about this we start in July we automated
this organization we now have 600
projects in the environment it took us a
couple months to get that invest in that
automation right but now we can change
labels and can change configurations on
projects across the entire environment
in five minutes it's fantastic it's the
only way we can really scale now this
next slide you've seen before but it's
so important I wanted to bring it up
again it is a process and it's important
to really nail down this process for the
very sake of the outcomes that Ramsey
indicated speeding up your migration
having repeatability having that
cornerstone of that project built in the
organization gives you consistency
across the entire environment so we do
things like create the project attach to
the VP see these are all service
projects by the way we delete all the
defaults we set up the identity access
management security the next poll is
really important you have to assign that
project to the correct billing account
right and also set up the usage data
that corresponds to that project and
then we enable api's and we set our
labels so that's the project Factory
let's pivot to asset management so we've
always been taught you know asset
management is the number one thing we
got to do in IT right so house asset
management translate up into the cloud
it's a little bit different you don't
have this static infrastructure you have
cloud services you have ephemeral
machines how is it that you gain the
insights into what you have in that
environment Asset Management's about
identifying organizing and allocating
and then being able to take action on
those assets so what do we do we wanted
to define our use cases in the cloud and
around assets so we came up with
financial use cases and operational use
cases and we define those labels and
then we assign those labels to the
project at the project level and
resources as we deploy resources that's
all tied to billing and usage data is
the billing and usage data that gives us
the accuracy the precision of what's
sitting in that cloud environment down
to the second what else can do that so
that's what we do we we set all this up
and then when the project gets built we
have that default set of label setup so
if a work load owner is moving up into
the cloud there's already preset labels
there while they're working in sandbox
getting their automation their pipelines
set up you know so they can actually
apply labels onto the resources they're
using and get down to a more granular
level but we have it at the project
level so we in the labeling strategy
produce these labels but there's a few
requirements that everyone needs to be
aware of and going to the GCP first of
all all labels need to be lowercase okay
they also can't have special characters
so some of our use cases require
notifying the owners of those assets we
can't use in special characters like
email addresses so you have to have a
solution that allows for that we
actually strip out those special
characters and spell it out and we're
able to then translate that back to the
right email address the other thing to
note is as you are reporting on the
information coming out of GC P is that
bigquery has all the columns for the
labels that you create
but services
are running at a different pace from
each other and how they're populating
the data into those those columns so as
some services mature they have you know
more information being placed out into
bigquery and so you just need to watch
for that as you get into the reporting
side our top 10 labels here as I said
financial use cases and operational use
cases we actually have two sets of
company and cost codes because on one
hand we want to track the aggregate
coming in from GCP from the billing
perspective the discounts and all that
but in the other and we want to be able
to allocate out to the workload owners
in the environment we want to track our
migration workloads so we have an
application ecosystem label we also
attract the environment sandbox non prod
prod the tier or this web app data tier
who the financial owner is of those
assets who the tech lead is and then
last but not least is who is going to
fix the problems that come up when they
are going to be alerted from the
monitoring right the resolver group so
wanted to do a little demo here and what
we're going to do is we're going to talk
about how to create the common variables
we're going to go into an old label
module and we're going to then show the
project label a project factory module
as well and ramage is going to help out
and take us to the source code it does
exist so what you see here you see a
number of modules we have as I was
describing firewall module we have the
IM module in that network but the one we
want to begin with is the terraform an
old label module if you open that up the
first thing that one needs to do is
declare their variables in the variable
TF
how many people here are really familiar
with terraform Oh beautiful right so I'm
telling you probably something you
already know but you got to declare your
variables here and as you can see we
have our mandatory labels defined with
the data types quite simple now as we go
into the main file it's a couple things
I want to show first thing we do have a
reference here to our confluence page so
anybody building out an old label file
can can reference you know our standards
or operating standards then we have a
little bit of work here to do to make
sure we conform to GCP requirements so
we said a couple redjac Express
expressions here to help clean up any
values that are coming in to the project
Factory and we use the kabob case to
transform any any capital letters to
lowercase and also to change any
underscores to hyphens and since you
have a lot of terraform developers here
you know what the kabab case is if not
you know it is a real thing you know
just like the snake case and the camel
case we use it here and the whole point
is that we can compartmentalize these
variables into a separate module we can
have some of this pre-processing like
this we can clean up the values so that
we conform to the GCP requirements now
we also reference in these kabab case
statements every one of the mandatory
labels right and once we're done with
that we can go to the project factory
module
and here's the the thing to note is the
very first thing is that we want to
reference that no label module right and
then reference the reference the
variables right that are going to be
used in this main TF file so we have
here reference all 10 of the core logic
mandatory labels and then as we scroll
down we also have information on the
project creation that needs to be
populated the project ID the
organization ID the folder ID and it's
vital that you add the billing account
and then we also have the network that
we attach to and then we reference the
label module again here so that when you
when you run the apply it's going to
pull labels from the right place right
okay so our engineers created this and
they set up a little example for us
wherever just hard code the the values
into into the the label variables and
you can see here the hard-coded values
going into the ten labels that we have
you know this is in the main TF file
that would be in the project factory
module but we don't do it this way we
use the dot t-- f VAR file right as part
of our pipeline so we can add a form in
front you know and automate the entire
process we do that for every one of our
modules right so takeaways from this is
modularize your terraform code leverage
the the modules to be able to separate
your variables and variable processing
from your main code and set up a
structure of proper structure that can
scale okay so flip oh now you can run
your plan and then run your apply
and with that then Ramsey I think we
would go to the GUI right and the GCB
console to take a take a look at that
it's good yeah we can flip over to the
slides please okay so everyone's
familiar with the GCB console yeah you
look under the I am and the admin
section and of course go to labels and
you see the key value pairs just that
simple
a couple of sample reports we just put
together out of this number one we want
to look at the aggregate by cost Center
and we have you know a lot of projects
that might group up under one primary
cost center or charge about costumers we
want to be OC how those cost centers are
trending second is in your migrations
you're going to want to track your work
packages and so having that ecosystem ID
to be able identify the package is
really helpful in a number of ways you
can see how that package is moving into
your sandbox into your nonprofits in to
prod also can see the effect of any of
your packages on the shared services
projects such as network or security
projects you start getting insights into
what is happening in your migrations
great and so with that thank you I'll
hand it back to your Branton cool thanks
Jim yeah so wanted just to summarize
some of the key takeaways from the
session I know we went over this
relatively quickly but it's really
important that you set these best
practices up early as you kind of saw
Jim Jim described you know CoreLogic had
these set of ten required labels and the
exercises that we actually stepped them
through early on was actually go through
and build that naming convention build
that key and value pair combination that
was not only relevant to the business
owners but that also made it really easy
for the developers to interpret and
incorporate that into their pipeline
automating the your project build so
this notion of project Factory is an
excellent
place to actually put a lot of your best
practices in control so really look to
the project creation to ingest a lot of
them a lot of those best practices as
possible using billing labels so one of
the things that we commonly see is that
either the labels aren't being
appropriate being attached in an
appropriate way
or they're inconsistent and actually
aren't structured in a uniform way that
makes sense to the business so we want
to encourage you to in use billing
labels but also make sure that you
incorporate those labels into your
infrastructure as code pipeline so take
all of these cost governance your
billing approach your billing account
association and then take that and then
really start to apply labels against
that and then make sure that you have
that incorporated in your CI CD pipeline
a few resources to leave you with so
there's a project internal to Google
called the cloud foundations toolkit
where a group of Googlers has actually
come together and built a standard set
of modules in both terraform and
deployment manager for things to solve
such as project creation associating
labels all the way up the stack into
things such as container deployments and
storage cloud storage as well some
resources if you're interested in
leveraging these modules you can
actually head over to github.com slash
terraform - google - modules and there's
an active community as I mentioned
through the terraform provider for GCP
there's also an active community within
Google building out those modules that
fit enterprise use cases so we want to
make sure that all the read needs and
content that we have you're able to
consume that and figure out how to scale
that across your deployments great and
so given this on the cost management
track I wanted to point you to a few
other sessions that fit into this space
so there's 12 sessions across cost
management you can actually meet the
product and product the product building
product team at the infrastructure Zone
on the showroom floor and if you would
like to actually see this session and
other ones alike you can actually visit
Google Cloud comm slash cost -
management for this video and others
[Music]